[Musique]
Antoine a 18 ans et la muoviciidose mais
il veut continuer à courir à l'hôpital
il rencontre Julie une vieille dame à
cariatre une histoire sortie de
l'imagination de deux étudiant le
réalisateur Jérôme rouagne et Marie
delzar la scénariste quand j'étais plus
plus jeune je suivais la star Académie
j'ai découvert la maladie comme beaucoup
de personnes en
France en suivant le phénomène Grégory
le et donc c'est de là que qui est venu
voilà cette envie d'en d'en parler et et
à ce moment-là je savais pas encore trop
comment pourquoi et puis voilà j'ai
commencé des études de cinéma et le film
de fin d'étude a été le bon moment pour
pour en
parler pour crédibiliser le le
personnage il fallait rencontrer un
pneumologue déjà pour comprendre la
maladie comprendre effectivement que
c'est pas quelque chose qui est
forcément physique euh c'est plus dans
l'attitude dans dans peut-être le
comportement aussi qu'on voit que une
personne est malade respire prend forme
en juillet 2015 avec l'écriture du
scénario le tournage s'est déroulé fin
février 2016 à rambouillé au cy un
centre de
rééducation se poser la question voilà
de de qui c'est ce personnage donc en
l'occurrence on a on a un personnage qui
est euh qui a atteint de la mucovicidose
qui aime le sport ça c'est le personnage
entre guillemets dans son aspect
caricatural mais c'est pas parce que moi
j'aime le cinéma que que je fais que ça
quoi donc c'estàd que par exemple sur
sur ma table de nuit il y a un super
Pixou géant donc à l'inverse lui
qu'est-ce que c'est que c'est ces
passions qui sont pas marqué en fait
dans dans le scénario quoi Victor meutel
vu dans la série Clem prête ses traits à
Antoine Julie la vieille dame est
interprétée par une Mar Villalonga très
en forme ma foi fa que je chante je
chanterai
tiens ma pauvre dame à votre âge
franchement justement à mon âge pauvre
con faire jouer Mar ça a été une
pression supplémentaire déjà parce que
voilà nous on est encore à l'école donc
on apprend aussi donc voilà on s'est dit
là il faut pas se planter elle en a vu
des grands et et voilà elle a tourné
énormément c'est une personne qui est
totalement dévoouée au projet au film et
donc finalement elle se laisse guider et
et voilà je pense qu'elle a pas été déçu
et nous en tout cas pas du tout on est
très très content de l'avoir eu sur ce
projet cétait une expérience formidable
respire devrait être présenté dans des
festival avant d'espérer sensibiliser le
public à la maladie au don d'organes aux
protagonistes resteront les
souvenirs